bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur Public Sénat 90 minutes
pour vous le savez donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos experts et voici
le sommaire de ce 20 septembre à la
tribune des Nations Unies volodymire
Zelenski accuse la Russie de génocide et
veut rallier les indécis à la cause de
la liberté le président ukrainien peut
aussi s'appuyer sur la percée de ces
soldats autour de darkmouth pour
convaincre les Occidentaux un enjeu
majeur car la guerre coûte cher le
soutien américain peut-il se tarir à
cause de la campagne présidentielle les
conséquences économiques de ce conflit
peuvent-elles pousser les Européens à
chercher une solution diplomatique on en
débat dans une minute et puis c'est une
première en France depuis près de 10 ans
et depuis plus de six siècles à
Marseille la visite d'un pape François
vient participer à des rencontres
réunissant des dizaines d'évêques et de
catholiques venus des 5 rives de la
Méditerranée le thème lui tient à cœur
les migrations
c'est une problématique
il y a un problème qui me préoccupe
c'est la Méditerranée c'est pour cela
que je vais en France à Marseille
l'exploitation des migrants et criminels
les crimes des passeurs le cynisme des
états le souverainpontif vieux veut
réveiller l'opinion internationale petit
parvenir sa parole symbolique peut-elle
peser par exemple sur le scrutin des
élections européennes réponse dans trois
quarts d'heure mais d'abord la guerre en
Ukraine donc au coeur de l'Assemblée
générale des Nations unies à New York
discours officiel tractation de couloir
le résumé avec Jérôme Rabier un an et
demi après le début de la guerre et face
aux risques de lassitude des alliés
internationaux volody mirzuelinski est
venu pour la première fois à l'ONU
l'enjeu pour lui est immense il faut que
les livraisons d'armes continuent pour
tenter de reconquérir un maximum de
territoires occupés mais aussi essayer
d'élargir le camp de ce qui défendent la
poursuite de la guerre même s'il veut
aussi lancer une initiative d'ouverture
de la paix je vous invite tous ceux qui
ne tolèrent aucune agression à préparer
conjointement ce sommet
une initiative dont on ne connaît pas
encore les contours les Ukrainiens
refusant jusque-là de parler de paix
sans retrait préalable des forces russes
mais en début de concession face au
monde non occidental majoritaire à l'ONU
qui ne manque pas de pointer le coût de
la guerre et l’absence de perspective de
paix avec le président brésilien en chef
de filtre
sous-estimons pas les difficultés
rencontrées pour parvenir à la paix mais
aucune solution ne sera durable si elle
n'est pas basée sur le dialogue
heureusement pour l'Ukraine le soutien
du président américain Joe Biden est
indéfectible seul chef d'État des cinq
membres permanents à avoir fait le
déplacement il a de nouveau promis que
les États-Unis seront toujours aux côtés
les Ukraine
nous devons nous opposer à cette
agression pure et simple aujourd'hui et
dissuadé d'autres agresseurs potentiels
demain c'est pourquoi les États-Unis
avec leurs alliés et partenaires du
monde entier continueront à soutenir le
peuple ukrainien dans la défense de sa
de son intégrité territoriale et de sa
liberté
dans le même temps l'armée américaine a
annoncé l'arrivée prochaine en Ukraine
des chars Abrams promis en début d'année
qui viendront impuyer les unités
ukrainiennes qui tentent depuis
plusieurs mois de percer les lignes de
défense russe en territoire occupés
voilà les enjeux de cette assemblée
générale des Nations unies au moment où
je vous parle volodimeki est en train de
s'adresser au Conseil de sécurité on en
débat tout de suite avec Gallia Ackerman
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes historienne
spécialiste de la Russie et directrice
de la rédaction du média en ligne desk
Russie belirnabli bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes professeur de droit à l'UPEC Paris
12 consultant international au cabinet
Lysias Partners et auteur de ce livre
relation internationale droit théorie et
pratique qui vient de paraître aux
éditions
bienvenue vous êtes professeur des
universités juristes et je cite votre
livre les Etats-Unis et la démocratie
parue aux éditions l'Harmattan Mathieu
crois Santo bonsoir Mathieu
politique donc il y a deux discours de
walladimir Zelenski qui se sont succédés
en 24 heures celui devant la tribu à la
tribune des Nations Unies et donc en
cette fin l'après-midi discours devant
le Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU Gaïa
Kerman c'est un enjeu on l'a vu dans le
sujet qui est quand même très important
pour voler et ainsi qu'est-ce qui vous
semble vous pour vous le plus essentiel
qu'est-ce quel message doit-il d'abord
faire passer
je crois qu'il porte le même message
depuis pratiquement le début de cette
guerre à savoir que c'est une pure
agression russe que la guerre ne peut se
terminer que par le retrait complet des
troupes russes du territoire ukrainien
en fait au début de la guerre
si vous souvenez la guerre a commencé le
24 février et en mars il y a eu une
sorte de négociation très bizarre par
pas de très haut niveau etc d'abord un
ministre ensuite
Istanbul
ou on parlait d'un compromis possible
c'est-à-dire le retrait des trompes
russes là où ils étaient avant
l'agression actuelle c'est à dire où ils
étaient au 23 février
2022 mais depuis la dynamique de la
guerre les le fait que le monde entier a
pu voir que l'armée russe n'était pas
aussi forte que cela
le fait que le peuple craignant a fourni
une résistance
à laquelle enfin personne ne s'y
attendait
permet aux Ukrainiens de dire non en
fait encore aujourd'hui même après plus
de 18 mois de conflit encore aujourd'hui
après plus de 18 mois de conflits et
peut-être en quelque sorte plus que
jamais parce que là ils sont en train
quand même de faire des percées
peut-être pas encore très significative
mais qui commence à porter les fruits un
certain nombre de villages bon on peut
plus parler de village c'est des
chandruine qui ont été qui ont été
repris et surtout il y a des frappes de
plus en plus nombreuses dans des
endroits où les Russes ne s'y attendent
pas les navires qui ont été collées etc
et donc il faut maintenant si on veut
avoir
et je pense que le sens de l'initiative
de la paix du Président zellenski c'est
exactement ça si on veut vraiment une
paix durable il faut que la Russie soit
vaincue sur le champ de bataille
d'accord alors il y a beaucoup de
thématiques parce qu'effectivement
volumes ce qu'il veut organiser un forum
pour la paix une grande réunion
internationale la question c'est qui
participe on pourra on pourra en
reparler mais le lien entre
des succès militaires et les messages
qui peut faire passer là en ce moment
aux Nations Unies pourquoi c'est si
important ben tout simplement peut-être
parce que le succès militaire ukrainien
est tout relatif
la contre-offensive n'a pas
véritablement réussi du moins telle
qu'elle était telle qu'elle a été
imaginée dans un premier temps à savoir
une contrepensive plutôt rapide et
efficace peut-être fantasmé par par les
observateurs occidentaux je ne sais pas
ou espérer par les quand même par
l'armée ukrainienne et parole de lumière
zenki oui alors fantasmer c'est
peut-être un mot un peu fort mais
c'était ce qui était attendu du côté
occidental dans la mesure où il y a un
investissement permettez-moi de parler
en ces termes c'est un investissement
diplomatique politique certes mais aussi
financier et la guerre coûte
elle coûte d'autant plus que elle est
longue donc il y a une pression
diplomatique qui monte côté occidental
pour que les Ukrainiens puissent avoir
des résultats dans la mesure il n'arrive
pas à obtenir des résultats
tangibles sur le terrain on tente côté
ukrainien
à mon avis aussi sur une inspiration
occidentale
d'avancer sur le plan diplomatique
pourquoi parce que Céline ski a été très
fort dans un premier temps dans cette
première phase qui a consisté à
constituer un bloc d'allier derrière lui
un blog d'allier essentiellement de
nature occidentale il a très bien réussi
cette première phase diplomatique par
contre il s'est rendu compte dans un
deuxième temps que c'était insuffisant
pour finalement
renforcer la position ukrainienne sur la
scène internationale dans la mesure où
la guerre malheureusement pour lui
peut-être est intervenu dans un moment
particulier de notre histoire qui est
celui d'une
reconfiguration de l'ordre international
une scène internationale de plus en plus
fragmentée qui ne se résume pas dans un
face-à-face entre d'un côté les
États-Unis ou le bloc occidental et de
la Russie ou même la Chine non en vérité
on est dans un monde multi polaire ou de
plus en plus multipolaire il s'en est
rendu compte et à partir de cette
seconde phase il a commencé à parler au
reste du monde pour
danser peut-être une troisième phase qui
pourrait réunir finalement tous ces
différents acteurs autour d'une même
table alors on va écouter et je vous
donne la parole juste après un extrait
de du discours de du président ukrainien
là en cette fin d'après midi donc devant
le Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies
donc on est on est vraiment dans un lieu
ultra symbolique du pouvoir à l'ONU et
c'est intéressant parce que autour de la
table il y avait quand même un
représentant de la Russie on en parle
juste après
la Russie a tué au moins des dizaines de
milliers de nos concitoyens et a fait
des millions de réfugiés en détruisant
leur maison la plupart des pays du monde
reconnaissent la vérité sur cette guerre
il s'agit d'une agression criminelle et
non provoquée de la Russie contre notre
nation visant à s'emparer du territoire
et des ressources de l'Ukraine
tes ressources
à lui à l'ambassadeur de de Russie aux
Nations Unies c'est une première depuis
que ce conflit a commencé est-ce que
est-ce que c'est une étape pour vous
est-ce qu'il faut relativiser parce
qu'en plus c'est une une assemblée
générale de l'ONU où tous les grands
chefs d'états sont pas présents le
Conseil de sécurité il y a cinq membres
deux sont absents puisque Poutine n'est
pas là et Chine n'est pas là non plus et
de toute façon il ne se passera bien
puisque il suffit d'un veto donc là
c'est vraiment pour le principe et il va
encore plus loin dans ses accusations
contre la Russie mais ce qui est
intéressant dans son discours devant
l'Assemblée Générale c'était le discours
d'hier et ça c'est vrai pour Biden aussi
c'est que tous les deux s'adressaient au
public et en public il faut même nuancer
parce que la salle n'était pas pleine il
y a un certain nombre de représentants
des États qui n'étaient pas là mais tous
les deux ça peut être s'adresser au sud
global c'est-à-dire à ceux qui ne
voulaient pas prendre parti parce qu'ils
ne veulent pas mettre en danger leur
relation avec la Russie c'est-à-dire
certains ont condamné l'agression mais
ne vont pas plus loin et par exemple ils
ne mettent pas en œuvre les sanctions et
donc
Vladimir zzisky s'adresse à eux en
disant mais attendez vous vous êtes
quand même concernés et que ça soit Lula
au Brésil que ce soit l'Afrique du Sud
que ce soit vous devez bouger parce que
sa grande phrase et on ne peut pas faire
confiance
au mal à la Russie niveau il faut pas
faire confiance il nous a trompé il a
semé la discorde la dissension etc il
dit il y a de la manipulation et à la
limite c'est Wagner mais on sait ce que
c'est la manipulation dans l'Afrique
francophone donc ça ça parle à un
certain nombre et là ça parle peut-être
aux pays africains qui sont en train de
se rendre compte que la mamie de la
Chine et la mamie de Wagner ce n'est
peut-être pas nécessairement une bonne
idée même si ils n'en sont pas encore à
revenir dans le giron de la France et
l'autre chose dans son discours qui
était intéressant il a Biden aussi
différemment dit la même chose il dit
quelque part il y a non seulement
l'agression contre nous et ensuite si on
ne stoppe pas la Russie ça peut aller
plus loin la Moldavie peut-être les pays
balles qui sont très très inquiets mais
surtout c'est la Russie qui est
responsable de l'envol du prix du
pétrole et de la pénurie alimentaire et
ça ça touche justement ces pays du Sud
global qui alors multi alignés il y a
tout un tas de terminologie mais
effectivement c'est plus le monde en
deux blocs c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
et Biden aussi il donne a dit il faut
continuer nous nous avons besoin
d'allier etc mais il parlait aussi à ses
états qu'il rencontre d'ailleurs sur un
plan bilatéral là il rencontre
l'occasion de rencontrer et
quand même cette assemblée des Nations
Unies c'est la grand-messe à Noël donc
ces pays du Global oui parce que ces
pays qui ne font partie ni du G7 ni du
G20 ils peuvent exprimer leur
préoccupations leurs colères ils ont
aussi le sentiment qu'on donne tout à
l'Ukraine et que donc il y a moins
d'aide disponibles pour eux j'ai le
souvenir qui a un an Emmanuel Macron
devant l'Assemblée générale des Nations
unies avait tenu bon normalement à peu
près ce discours qu'ils ont même une
forme de complicité ces grands pays ces
grandes puissances du globale qui se
taisait en tout cas qui ne prenait pas
partie
qu'est-ce qui pourrait faire changer
d'avis aujourd'hui peut-être
évoqué en fait ce qui a suscité la
crispation du côté de ce qu'on appelle
le sud global c'est le contraste
saisissant entre la mobilisation de
l'Occident dans son soutien à l'Ukraine
et son désintéressement par rapport à
certains engagements notamment en
matière d'aide au développement par
rapport à des pays qui sont
effectivement frappés
simultanément à la fois par le
creusement des inégalités et par le choc
lié au réchauffement climatique et
d'autant plus que dans le cadre onusien
il y a eu des engagements pris en la
matière dans le cadre des différentes
cops aussi et
si je schématise et vous trouvez très
vite des milliards pour l'Ukraine alors
que ça fait 10 ans que vous avez promis
100 milliards pour pour payer la dette
climatique je peux simplifier un petit
peu mais c'est c'est un peu le discours
c'est plus que le discours alors ce qui
est assez saisissant aussi c'est un
sentiment qui est vécu à la fois par les
élites de ces pays et par leur propre
société civile ce qui explique aussi
certains événements l'Afrique a été
évoquée c'est ce qui explique aussi
cette nouvelle séquence où on a
l'impression qu'il y a une montée de
d'un discours de
occidental c'est plus une réaction
vraiment de de par rapport au décalage
entre des postures des discours d'un
côté et des actes qui ne sont pas à la
hauteur d'autant plus que alors ça c'est
le versant un peu engagement et puis
vous avez le versant sanction lorsqu'il
faut sanctionner la Russie pour de
bonnes raisons à la fois du point de vue
je dirais légal juridique et pour des
raisons je dirais de justice
internationale on a su faire et on a été
rapide et efficace relativement efficace
mais en tout cas rapide et consensuel
lorsque dans des situations comparables
à savoir invasion d'un autre pays
annexion de territoire par une autre
puissance il y a un silence occidental
qui interroge tout autant on se dit mais
donc quelle est cette loi internationale
qui explique ou qui justifierait une
application à géométrie variable alors
on continue de s'appuyer sur des
extraits de discours de volley
mirzelinsky donc là on remonte 24 heures
en arrière discours à la tribune des
Nations Unies le président ukrainien qui
fait référence aux enfants de son pays
déportés en Russie il parle de centaines
de milliers d'enfants soumis à la
propagande russe
qui tout de suite parce que là on a une
photo de Joe Biden donc je ne pense pas
que ce soit le le la bonne interview
est-ce que vous avez l'élément on écoute
vos leaders merci beaucoup
en Russie on apprend à ses enfants la
haine de l'Ukraine et tous les liens
avec leurs familles sont coupés c'est
clairement un génocide
là aussi
nous a habitué à choisir ses mots
gaiakerman ce mot de génocide un sens on
y reviendra peut-être en droit
international est-ce que pour vous la
Russie est en train de tenter de
d'effacer l'Ukraine d'une certaine façon
sa culture sa langue son histoire bien
entendu et cet exemple d'enfants il est
très frappant parce que il y a eu plus
de 16000 enfants qui ont été vraiment
déportés tout seul sans famille pour
être russifié pour être placé dans des
familles russes etc on a coupé le lien
avec leur famille il est très difficile
de les trouver parce que souvent même on
leur change de nom donc ça c'est un
crime tout à fait clair et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que
et ça commissaire au droit d'enfance de
l'enfance
sont sous le coup d'un mandat d'arrêt
international pour génocide parce que je
ne cite pas seulement la mort physique
c'est aussi effacement d'un peuple d'une
ethnie par des moyens de de rééducation
par les moyens forcés et nous savons
maintenant 16 000 enfants en plus il y a
des centaines de milliers de familles
qui ont été forcés d'aller en Russie
parce que
c'était la seule voie d'évacuation
accessible souvent pendant les combats
les Russes ne permettaient pas que les
familles rejoignent l'Ukraine dans
beaucoup de cas mais ils les ont poussé
dans les républiques autoproclamés d'un
excluence qu'ensuite en Russie même et
là il s'agit en effet de centaines de
milliers d'enfants c'est les chiffres il
y a dizaines de milliers pour ceux qui
ont été vraiment coupé de leur famille
déportée et centaines de milliers la
Russie reconnaissent 740 750 000
familles accueillies je mets plein de
guillemets au terme accueillis
évidemment voilà donc donc maintenant il
y a encore quelque chose le la
rééducation et on sait ce que ça veut
dire dans la pratique ne se limite pas à
ses enfants déportés il y a aussi des
enfants dans les régions
occupées de l'Ukraine qui maintenant
doivent étudier selon le curriculum
russe souvent en russe mais même quand
c'est en ukrainien les manuels ont été
imprimés en Russie c'est-à-dire il y a
une doctrination
endocrinement pardon
donc encore
de centaines de milliers d'enfants
Ukrainiens qui sont l'avenir de la
nation il y a effectivement une
procédure j'appelle
ce qu'on appelle à la juris donc on peut
utiliser ce terme de génocide oui je
pense que il y a
une volonté d'effacer mais je devrais
pas dire ça mais ça me fait
malheureusement penser à ce qu'on fait
les Canadiens et les Américains avec les
Indiens là aussi on les a piqué dans les
tribus on les a mis dans des familles et
on les on leur interdit de parler leur
langue on les a mis dans des pensionnats
donc c'est quand même un problème alors
sur lequel les démocraties commencent à
revenir présenter des excuses dédommager
etc et je m'étonne d'ailleurs que
Poutine n'est pas encore ressorti ces
exemples pour dire vous vous l'avez bien
fait puisque quand même la grande
question c'est le double langage on
n'arrête pas de le dire les Américains
disent on fait saucisseur mais quand ils
ont besoin de faire ce qu'ils veulent
faire ils veulent et c'est bien ça
affaiblit finalement le le discours
occidental
les Russes et les
[Musique]
dedans et en même temps la légitimité de
son action en Ukraine il ne voit pas la
contradiction parce que précisément il
ne reconnaît pas la souveraineté de
l'Ukraine ou donc l'existence de l'autre
ça lui permet de donner un vernis légal
je j'emploie le à son à cette
intervention il essaye de transcender sa
contradiction en disant voilà notre
voilà ma conception de l'ordre
international
avec la Chine en particulier qui aussi
Martel le retour au respect de la
souveraineté pourquoi parce que derrière
pour eux c'est une manière de se
protéger contre toute forme d'ingérence
contre toute forme de critique c'est ça
que ça signifie aussi sauf que lui
maintenant est prisonnier de cette
contradiction dans la mesure où il s'est
engagé dans une aventure militaire qui
précisément l'inverse du respect de la
souveraineté alors tout simplement c'est
une traduction de de la non
reconnaissance de l'existence de
l'Ukraine combien de temps se le soutien
occidental peut-il durer c'est une vraie
question qui est pas abord ée dans les
discours officiels aux Nations Unies
mais sans doute un peu plus dans les
couloirs vous parliez de Joe Biden et de
son discours le président américain on
va on va l'écouter c'est vraiment
intéressant de rentrer dans le détail de
sa déclaration écoutons
comme tous les pays du monde les
États-Unis souhaitent que cette guerre
prenne fin aucune nation ne souhaite
plus que l'Ukraine que cette guerre
prenne fin nous soutenons fermement
l'Ukraine et ses efforts pour parvenir à
une résolution diplomatique qui garantit
une paix juste et durable seul la Russie
porte la responsabilité de cette guerre
seule la Russie a le pouvoir de mettre
fin à cette guerre immédiatement et
seule la Russie s'oppose à la paix car
le prix de la paix pour la Russie et la
capitulation de l'Ukraine le territoire
de l'Ukraine et les enfants de l'Ukraine
les mots sont clairs le soutien
américain l'est aussi il est même
financièrement important on le sait
est-ce qu'il peut s'effriter avec la
campagne présidentielle qui a clairement
commencé oui c'est un vrai risque c'est
la raison pour laquelle il profite des
derniers mois
à la fois pour rappeler son soutien
indéfectible à l'Ukraine pour s'assurer
que les alliés les occidentaux les
Français etc ne commence pas à faiblir
et pour là il a encore un paquet de 20
milliards de dollars qu'il essaie de
faire passer au congrès au total 40
milliards d'aides un total de 71
milliards de dollars d'aide et cela
commence à ticket en particulier du côté
républicain donc si on schématise au
Sénat la plupart des sénateurs sauf
trois républicains qui disent mais ça
nous coûte trop cher
occupons-nous du pays etc mais la
plupart des républicains comme Lindsay
Graham et McConnell sont pour la
continuation du soutien financier à
l'Ukraine le problème c'est un ou deux
des candidats à la présidence je vais en
parler dans une seconde mais surtout la
Chambre des Représentants la chambre et
le speaker mccarti sont prisonniers d'un
groupe ils sont 5 et j'ai très envie de
les appeler des tarés ce sont des
radicaux qui sont prêts à détruire le
pays pour par exemple
ils vont refuser à la fin de septembre
il y a plus d'argent il y a plus de
budget il refuse de voter les crédits
enfin comme chez nous pour le budget
américain là vous nous budget de l'aide
en Ukraine
or les républicains traditionnellement
étaient en faveur de l'armée du
Pentagone etc donc il y a des gens très
très dangereux que le speaker ne sait
pas tenir et on ne sait pas ce qui est
un vrai pouvoir de blocage oui là toute
cette semaine ils ont refusé les
résolutions pour les 12 résolutions
budgétaires qui financent les
différentes parties du budget américain
mais surtout ce qui est intéressant et
inquiétant ils se sont opposés au vote
sur le budget du Pentagone donc on a des
républicains et puis il y a un sénateur
qui bloque toutes les promotions donc en
fait il y a tout un tas de postes au
Pentagone qui ne sont pas pourvu donc il
faut voir que dans les dans les
républicaines il y a des gens très
hostiles et parmi les candidats le
second derrière Trump c'est 2 centimes
le gouverneur de Floride alors lui il a
un petit peu changé parce qu'il a
suscité intolé mais lorsqu'il a été
interrogé il y a deux mois il a dit
c'est un petit conflit régional qui
n'intéresse que l'Europe et donc le
message de Biden reprend ce que c'est un
combat pour la démocratie un combat pour
un ordre mondial fondé sur les règles au
fameux wall best order les Américains
depuis les années 45 depuis
l'après-guerre et donc ce n'est pas un
combat de l'Ukraine c'est un combat des
démocraties et nous devons lutter et il
espère qu'on va être mais il y avait un
éditorial du Washington Post ce matin
très intéressant qui disait deux choses
un Biden a trop tardé à chaque fois
qu'il y a des demandes d'arbres ça prend
très très longtemps or il a fini par
tout donner il a fini d'ailleurs
pardonner les F-16 les missiles etc
plutôt voilà parce qu'il dit toute façon
les Français les Britanniques ont donné
des missiles et se sans doute des
missiles français ou anglais qui ont
touché les bateaux la semaine dernière
donc il dit nous traînons trop et dit
deuxième chose il dit Biden devrait
s'adresser au peuple américain pour
faire comprendre les enjeux et lui
expliquer que le conflit va durer pour
qu'il y ait dans l'opinion une prise de
conscience que c'est un conflit qui
n'est pas con Ukraine ça veut dire que
le temps joue pour Vladimir Poutine
aujourd'hui c'est possible vous savez je
pense que pas seulement byden devrait
s'adresser au peuple américain mais tous
les présidents européens devraient
s'adresser à leur peuple parce que il y
a très peu de conscience dans nos
sociétés des enjeux de cette guerre il y
a beaucoup de propagandes russes depuis
des années et donc quand un peu de
lassitude aussi c'est triste à dire mais
les conséquences économiques de la
guerre c'est peut-être ce que ressentent
prioritairement les citoyens européens
c'est-à-dire l'inflation une crise
économique qui voilà qui est perçue au
quotidien donc ça joue sur la la
réaction des opinions publiques
occidentales et notamment européenne
donc vous dites il faudrait que les
chefs d'États européens redonne du sens
à ce conflit c'est ça absolument qu'il
redonne le sens qu'il mobilise davantage
le plus long public il y a tout un
travail
de persuasion à faire explications je
pense que il faut en effet augmenter le
budget le budget militaire dans tous les
pays de l'OTAN et il faut bien entendu
fournir davantage
d'aide à l'Ukraine parce que les gens ne
comprennent pas qu'en fait cette guerre
même si pour l'instant elle ne nous
menace pas directement ça peut se
transformer en un conflit de grande
amplitudes et pour que cela n'adienne
pas il faut agir aujourd'hui alors on va
continuer de parler de ce de ce soutien
militaire des Occidentaux avec la
chronique de Jonathan du priez ce qui va
nous rejoindre tout de suite sur ce
plateau bonsoir Jonathan bienvenue
Bienvenue à vous on va surtout parler de
la formation des soldats Ukrainiens ils
commencent à affluer en Europe pour se
former donc dans les pays de l'Union oui
Thomas pas moins de 26000 hein
militaires on dort déjà été formés dans
l'Union européenne dans 24 des 27 États
membres et c'est surtout l'Allemagne
prend la plus grande part de ses
formations avec 10000 soldats qui ont
été formés et la France c'est environ
5000 est-ce qu'on le remarque et puis
c'est pas vraiment un hasard c'est qu'en
pleine contre-offensive
ukrainienne et bien lieu accélère
drastiquement le rythme de ces
formations de manière très significative
les 27 ils ambitionnent de former
jusqu'à 40 000 soldats Ukrainiens d'ici
à 2024 c'est 4 fois plus que ce qui
était envisagé en octobre dernier
qu'est-ce qu'il y a on les forme à quoi
alors les formes a beaucoup de choses et
c'est un éventail qui est très vaste il
y a environ 400 formations qui ont été
mises en place par l'Union européenne et
lieu communique sur le fait que c'est
vraiment du sur mesure du coup humain ça
va de l'entraînement militaire de base
pour des militaires néophytes à
l'utilisation de chars ou des munitions
qu'on a pu leur livrer et il y a aussi
des formations supports notamment pour
les médecins pourquoi pas aussi du
déminage et voire même peut-être de la
maintenance pour ces fameux matériels et
à cela s'ajoute bien sûr les les
formations dispensées par d'autres pays
de l'OT an qui collaborent alors les
États-Unis sur le sol ou européen mais
aussi la Norvège comme vous le voyez là
sur ces sur ces images ou des soldats
une centaine sont à l'entraînement pour
se former au tir de précision au tir
d'élite et certains apprennent aussi le
commandement sur le terrain écoutez
ce que je dois apprendre avant toute
chose c'est commander comment faire
fonctionner une équipe car à mon retour
en Ukraine je deviendrai chef d'équipe
la principale chose que nous enseignons
est le leadership comment contrôler le
champ de bataille comment contrôler les
hommes et comment enseigner plus tard
quand il reviendront chez eux
donc ces formations elles fonctionnent
plutôt bien mais il y a quand même des
freins il faut évidemment que ça aille
très vite puisque l'Ukraine ont subodore
qu'elle a des pertes très lourdes même
si on ne connaît pas les chiffres donc
il faut leur fournir vite des hommes
formés pour retourner au front il y a
aussi le niveau des recrues qui arrivent
certains ont connu le champ de bataille
certains ne l'ont pas encore connu donc
il faut adapter la formation à ce à leur
niveau et puis aussi la barrière de la
langue c'est assez compliqué il faut
trouver des traducteurs et l'Union
européenne en tout cas dit qu'elle s'est
saisi de cette question qui est quand
même assez cruciale merci beaucoup
Jonathan pour toutes ces précisions
Bel-Air Nabil la 15e réunion de
coordination de l'aide militaire a eu
lieu cette semaine sur la base de
Rammstein en Allemagne l'info principal
c'est la livraison de chats alors là on
revient au char américain de Charles
Abrahams et pour pourquoi c'est
important est-ce que ça peut changer la
donne ça oui parce que c'est une
capacité qui manque dans l'arsenal de
l'armée ukrainienne tout simplement et
c'est une demande qui commence à dater
le problème c'est les délais de les
délais pour fournir concrètement ces
d'ailleurs c'est une problématique qu'on
retrouve au niveau de l'aviation
militaire côté
ukrainien ce qui est intéressant c'est
d'allier ou de lier peut-être ces
retards avec un déficit de volontarisme
politique personne n'a osé jusqu'à
maintenant poser cette équation sur la
table mais on promet mais on
prend tellement de temps pour livrer qui
a forcément un manque de volonté
politique derrière c'est ce que vous
nous dit en tous les cas c'est ce qu'on
peut comprendre de certaines crispations
du côté du président zaninski qui il y a
encore quelques semaines quelques mois
n'arrêtait pas de de monter en gamme
dans
il ne l'a jamais dit en ces termes mais
à un moment donné il a il a fait part de
ses doutes presque de ses interrogations
quant à quant au délai de fournitures et
on peut pas
écarter finalement certaines tensions
peut-être dans les processus de décision
soit
militaire soit politique dans certains
états pour arriver concrètement à ce
qu'on est enfin côté ukrainien accès à
ce type d'armement Mathieu beaucoup
d'observateurs au début du conflit ont
été surpris par la résistance de
l'Ukraine comme si on avait un peu
sous-estimé l'Ukraine est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui à l'inverse on n'est pas
en train de sous-estimer la Russie
est-ce que la Russie peut perdre
militairement cette guerre parce qu'elle
tient non vous avez raison on a du mal à
apprécier à sa juste mesure les forces
russes pourquoi parce qu'on a été
confronté aussi à la propagande russe je
vais prendre un exemple c'est la
modernisation de l'armée russe c'est
quelque chose qui a été
martelé
durant ces dernières années côté
Vladimir Poutine pour essayer et ça
prend sa compagnie vraiment son discours
sur la restauration de la puissance
russe sur la scène internationale et
pour lui cette restauration passée par
une modernisation technologique d'une
armée vraiment
héritière de la de l'armée soviétique
et il est tenté de faire la
démonstration de cette modernisation à
travers un certain nombre d'exercices à
travers aussi l'intervention russe en
Syrie
et donc on a pu croire que l'armée russe
notamment c'était modernisée qu'elle
avait les moyens de de sa volonté de
puissance si j'ose dire bon dans un
premier temps ça s'est pas concrétiser
sur le terrain ou sur le territoire
ukrainien il n'empêche la guerre dure et
moi je crois que le temps joue en faveur
de la Russie notamment dans ce reg être
là puisque dans un deuxième temps
l'armée russe a pu s'adapter
stratégiquement tactiquement
à l'équation ukrainienne votre avis
là-dessus est peut-être je rajoute un
élément dans dans la question de à la
question de de Mathieu sur là on a un
peu plus de recul l'impact de l'épisode
Wagner de ce putsch raté et puis
finalement de de alors j'allais dire de
l'élimination voilà on peut peut-être
employer ce terme-là de prix gaugine que
voilà est-ce que vous pouvez lier les
deux les deux aspects l'état de force de
l'armée russe aujourd'hui et l'effet de
du putschland manqué
je dirais tout d'abord pour rebondir sur
ce qui a été déjà dit
c'est que cette lenteur certaines
lenteurs pour fournir les armes à
l'Ukraine dont elle a besoin s'explique
en partie en tout cas par la peur de
l'Occident des États-Unis notamment
qu'est-ce qui va se passer si le crâne
gagne vraiment si la Crimée tombe ça va
produire un séisme politique en Russie
Vladimir Poutine pourrait perdre le
pouvoir
certaines républiques
peut autonome République réclamait le
réindépendance qu'est-ce qui va se
passer avec les armes nucléaires etc je
pense qu'il y a une vraie peur de ce
scénario tout comme les pays
occidentaux avaient très peur de
l'éclatement de l'Union soviétique
mais pas trop pas trop fort non plus
et ça c'est ça c'est un très gros
problème maintenant pour
l'état de l'armée russe
en effet l'armée russe
vous savez c'est comme pendant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale
on se prépare à une guerre éclair comme
Hitler avec l'invasion de l'Union
soviétique et puis ça se dégonfle parce
que la résistance est plus forte
qu'espérait là Poutine pensait faire un
Blitzkrieg
l'armée n'était pas préparée pour ça
c'est ce qu'on a dit dans les premiers
mois parlons nous interrompre c'est
toujours vrai aujourd'hui pour vous il
n'y a pas eu de problème de modification
du modèle donc l'armée l'armée n'avait
même pas assez de vivre à cette munition
etc etc d'où bien sûr les résultats
catastrophiques de la première année de
guerre
maintenant ce qui s'est passé c'est que
la société russe s'est soudée davantage
autour de Vladimir Poutine parce que
d'une part c'est la propagande d'autres
parts c'est un raisonnement tout simple
mon pays est en guerre qu'elles soient
juste pas juste moi il faut il faut que
je participe et donc et donc là ils vont
faire probablement une deuxième vague de
mobilisation mais même sans cette
deuxième vague il y a beaucoup de
volontaires parce que ils sont très
grassement payés et donc ce qui se passe
c'est que c'est là qu'on voit que la
Russie a quand même trois fois et demi
plus d'habitants donc plus de personnes
mobilisables et si ces personnes
mobilisables sont très bien payées et
bien il ne Régine pas tant que ça
mot c'est incroyable nous parlons depuis
45 minutes nous n'avons pas mentionner
le temps et l'article 5 quand même ce
qui freine qui freine les Occidentaux
lorsqu'ils à donner des armes des chars
etc
la prochaine livraison soit interprétée
comme étant une attaque du camp
occidental contre la Russie donc il faut
il faut quand même dire ça moi la
livraison peut-être que l'usage de la
livraison c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment
donné si vous commencez à fournir des
missiles
les environs de Moscou ça change la
donne évidemment dans la signification
politique dans la réponse possible de de
Vladimir Poutine et là aussi j'aurais
quand même vous entendre sur ce que
Karman disait à l'instant sur le la peur
et peut-être des Occidentaux d'une
destin d'une telle déstabilisation de de
la Russie et de la région en cas de
défaite militaires de Poutine je ne suis
pas une spécialiste et j'ai peu on
entend ça
américaine
d'autant il y a beaucoup de critiques
beaucoup d'analyses de pourquoi ça prend
30 ans etc d'analyse de politiques
politicienne sur les républicains que se
passer il faut aussi se rendre compte
que Poutine joue la montre car son
espoir c'est que Trump soit élu et quand
on regarde les songes on constate que
Trump à toutes les chances d'être
investi le candidat investi du parti
républicain et que dans un remake de
2020 il a autant de chances que Biden
d'être élu donc c'est inquiétant pour
certains d'entre nous moi en particulier
c'est très très rassurant pour Monsieur
Poutine alors on va je vous donne la
parole mais je voudrais qu'on reste sur
les questions de
l'option diplomatique et je vous propose
une réaction c'est celle du toujours
assemblée génération du dis celle du
président en turc c'est celle-là que je
voudrais entendre tout de suite
récepteur
erdoğan qui devant l'Assemblée alors
c'est intéressant là aussi les mots qui
l'emploi écoutez bien ils parlent à la
fois de l'Ukraine et de la Russie dans
les mêmes termes
Lucia
nous nous sommes efforcés de garder nos
amis russes et ukrainiens autour de la
table avec l'idée que la guerre n'aura
aucun vainqueur et la paix aucun perdant
nous allons intensifier nos efforts pour
mettre fin à la guerre grâce à la
diplomatie et le dialogue sur la base de
l'indépendance et de l'intégrité
territoriale de l'Ukraine nos amis
russes et ukrainiens bon c'est les mots
ont un sens a-t-il un vrai rôle tient le
président turc aujourd'hui dans
l'hypothèse d'une option ou d'une issue
diplomatique incontestablement d'abord
de manière générale son rôle s'inscrit
précisément dans ce nouvel ordre
international qui se dessine ou
précisément des puissances moyennes ou
des puissances régionales réussissent à
se faire entendre parce que parce que
les deux grandes puissances mondiales ou
quelques grandes puissances mondiales ne
suffisent pas ou n'arrive pas à réguler
l'ordre international ils ont besoin
d'appui
et c'est là où des voix comme celle
d'Erdogan ou de Lula à l'assemblée
générale se font entendre parce que il y
a un rôle à jouer celui de pivot c'est
ce qu'elle sait aussi de jouer comme
rôle le président indien le Premier
ministre indien pardon me dit qu'il a vu
cette brèche dans cette nouvelle
configuration il faut bien qu'à un
moment donné on arrive à articuler les
prises de position des uns et des autres
et puis vous avez justement des chefs
d'État ou de gouvernement qui veulent
jouer ce rôle là Erdogan c'est ce qu'il
essaye de faire depuis le début de la
guerre il le fait plutôt bien sur le
plan diplomatique rappelez-vous les
premiers contacts après le déclenchement
de la guerre les premiers contacts et
les premières négociations diplomatiques
officielles officielle entre russe et
ukrainien c'était sous l'égide de la
Turquie et puis vous avez d'autres
d'autres exemples
spectaculaires c'est notamment son rôle
de pivot de
d'intermédiaire dans dans la crise des
céréales et de des pores autour de la du
sud de l'Ukraine
Annecy est-ce que vous avez parlé des
difficultés à faire voter les budgets de
de guerre notamment à cause de des
réticences des républicains mais est-ce
que au sein de l'administration Biden
l'option diplomatique gagne du terrain
le temps passant pas vraiment quand on
écoute Jackson Heaven le conseiller à la
sécurité nationale il explique que
l'enjeu c'est vraiment la défaite de la
Russie parce que tout le monde est
concerné là le général
prend sa retraite donc il a été
interviewé un peu partout et il a le
même langage il explique que c'est
absolument normal d'avoir consacré tout
cet argent et qu'il faut continuer
l'effort donc pour le moment et c'est
pour ça que ce serait intéressant que
Joe Biden s'adresse aux Américains
il y a je pense qu'il y a un décalage
entre les élites politiques qui dans
l'ensemble sont d'accord pour soutenir
l'Ukraine et le peuple américain
quand on voit qu'en France il y a pas
une grande conscience on se dit qu'aux
États-Unis c'est encore plus lointain et
qu'à part peut-être de temps en temps un
criminé la guerre pour
l'inflation qui est beaucoup plus
importante aux États-Unis qu'elle n'est
en France et en Europe l'essence est
cher même si elle a un petit peu
rebaissée la nourriture à grimper de 20%
en quelques mois donc l'Américain moyen
voit les conséquences et lui n'est sans
doute pas très d'accord pour que l'on
continue à dépenser ces sommes et à cet
égard ce qu'a dit Joe Biden devant
l'assemblée générale c'est moi je suis
prêt à continuer et il s'est démarqué de
America First de Donald Trump lui
voudrait que le monde entier bénéficie
et il ne veut pas donner son argent
seulement au peuple américain même si
dans sa campagne il explique qu'il est
là pour ouvriers le col bleu et pour
établir un peu d'égalité aux États-Unis
merci beaucoup merci à tous je vais
rappeler les titres de vos livres
Indochine les États-Unis la démocratie
publié aux éditions et je sais pas si on
les a mais peut-être pas voilà merci
beaucoup bravo et believe Nabli relation
internationale droite théorie et
pratique aux éditions Peden Gallia
Karman je rappelle que on peut vous
suivre notamment sur le média en ligne
desk Russie merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat et à bientôt sur
public